hey everyone how's it going in this
JavaScript tutorial I'm going to talk
about the different operators in
JavaScript what I want to do is a really
quick pass over the most common
operators you'll see out there in the
wild most of these will be centered on
comparison and arithmetic operators so
that when we get to conditionals and
control flow code we'll have already
covered conditional operators in this
video now by the end of this video you
should have a solid understanding of the
most common operators leaving the door
open for moving on to more advanced
topics like control flow and if
statements to start most operators in
JavaScript are either unary meaning
operates on the single operand or binary
meaning it operates on two operands now
there's a special ternary or three
operand operator but we'll cover that in
conditionals later you can ignore it for
now a unary operator is one that
requires a single operand or argument so
it looks kind of like this operator and
then argument or goes argument operator
and a binary operator looks more like
this so it'll be like argument 1
operator argument 2 so keep that in mind
as we go over the different operators
today because we're gonna have some of
them that are unary operators and some
of them are gonna be binary operators
just put these in comments that you can
refer to them as we look we're gonna
start with assignment operators
assignment operators are when you set
the value to something so the most
familiar one should be something like at
a equal ten you've got an equal sign
here you've got operand one and you've
got operand 2 now after that they're a
bunch of assignment operators that are
kind of like a merge between assignment
operators and arithmetic operators we
haven't covered arithmetic operators yet
but you can kind of guess that they're
plus minus multiplication division that
kind of thing so if you go like a plus
equals one this is just a convenience
way of looking at this AE equal a plus
one they're basically the same thing
it's just a really quick and easy way of
writing it so that you don't have to
write the full statement now you can do
this for a lot of the arithmetic
operators so you can do that for
subtraction which is really equal to a
minus one you can do it for
multiplication which is equivalent to a
times two and you can do it for division
which is equal to a divided by two and
finally there is the modulo which is
equivalent to a a13 I'll cover what
modulo does in a minute but the point
here is that you've got these assignment
operators and what they do is they
assign the value from the right side to
the left side now let's take a look at
the arithmetic operators
and these are comprised of mainly the
standard arithmetic operators that you
might be familiar with from other
programming languages such as addition
subtraction multiplication division and
division with remainder now I'll work
with numbers here just so you can see
the values so beginning with addition a
plus 1 you can guess that if a is 10
then this will be equal to 11 a minus 1
if a is 10 then this will be equal to 9
and a multiplied by 2 if a is 10 then
this will be equal to 20 and if a is 10
and a divided by 2 then this will be
equal to 5 now the only slightly tricky
one here is the modulo or the division
with remainder what this does is it does
the division but instead of giving you
the result there it gives you the
remaining value to give an example I'll
use real numbers here so 10 divided by 3
that is equal to 3 with a remainder with
a remainder of 1 so 10 mod 3 is equal to
1 now 10 divided by 3 is actually 3
points for you but we're just going to
use indicator division if you now know
and you can see that modulo is the
remainder after division integer
division
now this modulo operator might seem a
little bit of special case but it's
actually really really important and
commonly used often I use it when I'm
iterating lists for example we'll get to
it later when we start talking about lit
for loops and that kind of thing
especially when you get to for loops and
arrays for now understand how it works
we'll be covering use cases quite a bit
later on now there's a couple more
arithmetic operators that you may see
and remember where I talked about unary
versus binary operators all the ones
that we've covered so far have been
binary operators but these next three or
all unary operators meaning they operate
only on a single operand so a plus plus
or plus plus a this is called the
increment operator and depending on how
you use it it will either increment the
value and then return it or return the
value and then increment it afterwards
so imagine that a equals one and you go
let B equals a plus plus in that case
since the plus plus comes after or it's
a what's called postfix then it will
return the value before incrementing so
B should be equal to one but then a will
be equal to two once this runs now have
you do the same thing now if you do the
same thing but the plus plus is the
prefix then it will increment a before
returning the value meaning B will be
two and a will be to the next arithmetic
operator is the decrement operator so a
minus minus or minus minus minus minus a
and that operates exactly the same way
as the plus plus except it decrements
instead of increments and we're not
going to go through an example because
we just ran through it for plus plus
let's give these names here
and finally the last arithmetic operator
that we're going to cover today this
isn't all of them but this is good
enough this is the negation and what it
does is it negates the value so if you
can't see that that's a minus sign and
if you were to go something like that B
equals negative a all you have to do is
add the minus symbol and it negates the
value it's equivalent to multiplying by
negative one now I like I said this
isn't technically all of the earth
medical operators but it's most of them
and probably the ones that you'll need
in the near future and the last thing I
want to go over is the comparison
operators so let's go over these first
up is equals equals so what happens if
you go a equals equals B what this does
is it checks whether or not the two
operands are equal so a does not equal
to B as you might guess the checks
whether or not a does not equal B so
while a equal equals B would return true
if they were the same a does not equal B
would return true if they are not the
same now we have something called strict
equal and what this does is it's really
similar to equals equals except that the
extra equal sign indicates that you also
want to check whether or not the types
are exactly the same and just like
equals equals there is a strict not
equals then we get into some of the
other comparison ones so let's say that
you have a greater than B that checks
whether or not is a is greater than B so
if a is 10 and B is 5 then 10 is greater
than 5 and that's true for example is
less than
that's doesn't be this would be checking
whether or not a is smaller than B is
greater than or equal to B so this is
the greater than or equal to operator
and it just checks whether or not the
left operand is greater than or equal to
the right operand and you can imagine
that there is the exact opposite so a is
less than or equal to B and so for the
most part those are the different ways
to do comparisons this was pretty
information dense and I kind of sped
through a lot of these but there are a
lot of operators to cover and I didn't
want to drag this out for two or three
hours while we went into deep examples
and code for each one you should be able
to play with these and get to know them
there's quite a few operators here and
we only covered just a fraction of the
ones that exist in JavaScript but
there's a lot of repetition here as well
once you get to know one or a few of
them you kind of get to know the rest in
the series anyway that about wraps up
the different operators in JavaScript
you should have at least a passing
understanding now of how they work and
what the different operators are if you
have any questions or concerns or you
just want to follow up on something that
was said in the video let me know in the
comments below but that about wraps up
this video in the series I hope you
enjoyed it and I'll see you soon
Cheers